three
oh
oh yeah yeah yeah oh right oh
alrighty then so macquarie the former president
elect biden
oh um
you think jim carey's enjoying the catfish
no he just said today he's not
going to really know that he won't
be rick healey
only then welcome i want to do
it smarter welcome to freedom ah we
are of course the pretzel gang we
are the pretzel gang wear them three
boy crocodile crew i'm scott i'm lauren
and speaking of the crocs collab who
has hated
my crocs by the way wow and
i've been wearing them later i've been
wearing them around the house behaviors i
welcome you i love my haters haters
are talking about me i wish a
new year to my haters including her
um i want to wish a happy
new year to all the haters not
to the losers sorry you lost again
wow yeah but she i've been wearing
them around the house because
it's been really cold and the floor
in my office and there's so cold
they aren't working so well these ones
have to have like a fur in
them oh that's wrong remember how i
said there was yes you splurge i
don't want new ones i returned mine
but i know we're waiting for you
to get your proper crocs we can
take a group photo but i really
like go through the web
site a lot so she hates them
and she makes fun of me anytime
i'm wearing them but she's now taken
to buying charms for them and surreptitiously
puts them on that's very funny so
i have now on one i have
an avocado dip with tortilla chips fucking
hilarious and real likely
and then i have a piece of
sushi hung together she does this overnight
just like the cobbler's l yes exactly
i'm sorry that's great that is great
that's not a hater that's a true
fan was somewhat what are some of
her burns on your crocs um she
isn't you know they're ugly yeah i'm
ugly oh my parents are ugly that's
unrelated to
the crux
just sets her off
so how do you choose red ray
j filming look down and see those
charles i there they're stupid but you
like it because i will say our
friend ah j j ah took a
instagram picture of her crocs and she
has a lot of charms on them
and cool up was like maybe i
like crocs now because i think she's
very influenced by friends yeah she thinks
are cool
lol sure this jj abrams we're talking
yes
there was like a lens flare we
call something called the croc master jessica's
crocs look really cool and i don't
like here's the thing i don't know
i don't know if i have the
proper ankle foot ratio like how much
angle do you need per foot like
i look at her ratio i never
thought about
me neither but but crocs are a
weird shape and i look at her
foot and i'm like they look so
cute on her with those charms or
didn't do or years i think i
got too fat or like coercion is
like an good way and i'm like
i have big fee you know like
i yeah i can accept that and
i don't care if people
will want to hate on it
i think i think they look they're
ugly no matter who puts them on
oh my well there goes my feet
my wiki beat score is fantastic really
isn't because you're tall i have a
feeling any long toe anyone who has
long bones gets a better way my
own wikipedia by the way it was
just women doing low man on there
but see i don't know if you've
shown your fee i have
to show my feet in some episode
of comedy bang bang right now maybe
ok well got kula popped up oh
great you are you care what's her
score yeah she's got nice feet four
out of five stars out of five
that's a bad what what do you
need to get out all votes okay
well fifty five weirdos
commenting on her field nationwide foot fetish
just say when i read fifty five
wiki feed scott aquaman and it showed
collapse so that's interesting how they nesting
so one in every state
yeah and the protectorates and therefore others
in texas see i have five stars
beautiful feet i've got five stars
how many votes seven hundred thirty seven
oh yea um um what have you
shown your feet in a lot of
things and and and and red carpet
and stuff with like you know sandal
type shoe okay find them anywhere they
find them wherever you put them and
my wedding photo is here you know
like that's that's that's
not it's personal but then my feet
look good
supra so everyone go to wiki feed
and give lore and some extra votes
reason votes to cool up all your
cool upvotes and definitely don't try to
fucking skew it negatively you know yeah
don't try to run rotten tomatoes ghostbusters
yeah hey it's exactly you don't vote
for the worst don't don't don't american
idol so yeah we see paul's on
there and then jay no
no we shall not nor should we
um no you're not
oh we weren't going to do it
one of the pretzel gangs says notice
something don't we have to immediately start
is to write down our bylaws yes
it was a treasurer but i typed
in wiki feed paul tomkins on google
showed me a tweet that you may
want it and the how dare you
i know this tweet it says please
put me on wiki
i don't get out of this ankara
wiki tweet wikitree and it just has
all your tweets and their beautiful tweets
no way that we use twitter four
out of five beautiful tweets um it's
some behind the scenes footage of meeting
a cool voice now why is that
connected to wiki fee what it's from
freedom because there's scenes
equally nobel
oh sure do remember this i do
remember this yeah you're tweeting our voices
paul without our permission or consent they
can sue you good luck i'll do
it okay see you there anyone out
there you might get there a little
early breakfast can we do it later
i guess we got afternoon court i
know there's no court they never talk
about afternoon court
yeah buddy you maybe hey there night
court reboot coming soon chord school well
it's still a reboot isn't it it's
ah well it's not a reboot because
he's playing the same character john larocca
it's not a reboot it's ah i
guess yeah they booted succumb but when
you call a sql for something they
don't call it a reboot not been
on the air for
thirty years i guess to jake's it's
a three hundred to jake's it's such
an intense here's my question and i'm
mad about reboots and sequels but i'm
wondering if that guy da da sad
mad about reba nam sequel i'm not
sad
but iran contra ceo is this is
this what happens when time continues and
whoa you're blowing fucking my house and
there are so many tv yeah channels
and blah blah blah blah blah we
have no new ideas when we have
to go back to the guy involved
in something that is a hit so
it can
be rebooted so i can get some
money down the line do you know
here's my ah i don't know why
how i made this connection but when
i read an action is me
we gotta say that ever anytime a
connection is made on this every time
yeah anytime a connection is made we
have to just infer that connection not
just any time somebody says it but
no time zone someone makes a connection
between two things okay okay an action
is made
go ahead i forget what anyway ah
so i read the news the news
the newsboy comes to my chakra news
happen what does that mean that jon
leuer kit to make a night night
court sql ah i went to i
think because i was thinking like who's
still alive and so there
are all yeah so i've except for
harry anderson of course so comedy bang
bang star
the most best-known for comment can i
say star of night court like a
central player yeah it'll lead i know
but i'm saying like so it's interesting
to go we're gonna do a sql
now without this key person yes let's
let's make it let's sit around the
character i had the least amount of
depth well i will say john larocca
won all the emmys four
it right he didn't only emmys for
playing a disgusting man yeah really was
a perverted november that was his whole
thing he was perfect i was a
kid you know i think he's like
merv the purr of over here in
in becoming more of his oeuvre the
per oh that's true what does this
banner say write happy birthday maybe i'm
not sure we had a birthday ah
socially disc
in celebration for ah a friend it
says tonight because everyone says bright and
who they were only three people birthday
guy one other friend and you wanna
tell us who it was springsteen ah
no i don't alright okay ooh
hey mr president
so i thought what and to be
fair they did give john larry kids
character little shading as the series went
off shore you have to but still
use perf um i thought what about
a sequel plus your silly lauren lucas
thank you thank you for not sneezing
on the equipment what is the
oh bless your silly ass i know
this isn't it i feel like that's
the thing that we said i i've
said it when people sneeze for awhile
okay paul i was like a a
sql two e t o with grown-up
elliott and e t being reunite and
she called e two
and elliott it's like it's like ah
cobra kai were elliott's like a piece
of shit now now see cobra kai
i was like i'm i can't i'm
so confused everyone's watching this like mike
was like really so much used to
television show and people watch it i
just was like this seems like it's
not for adults like i was confused
by
my brother was really intuitive mike was
really into it and then i watched
it and i really liked it yeah
just really well done yeah but i
was really surprised by that like so
it was an example of one of
the sequels that i thought did a
good job yeah but i think there
are a couple of the spielberg canon
like um close encounters yeah what what
operate
so like what them with that guy
comes back to earth then aren't all
of the questions answered you know and
and the whole point of that movie
is like oh holy shit like there's
probably life out there and outer space
and we all heal we all wanna
know but then it ends right before
it gives you the answers you know
yeah i'd like those answers oh waited
long enough
but i would love to see e
t and elliot reunited what about i
don't want to see close encounters aliens
fighting that i want to know if
i want to see e t and
t v elliott they will encounter realise
all three movies at the same time
what do you think the plot is
and drew barrymore isn't it yes drew
barrymore rosanna everybody's in i guess
z wallace you know what's here here's
what happens then it's gonna have to
be about their kid peter coyote isn't
like julie taymor and oh yet live
next door to peter coyote and they
have kids of their own families and
then they have what do you what
what what i was with my thumb
is that i'm pro oh
says okay
it took me a second to process
i think that's a new campbell thing
we would always talk about
on the tv show oh my god
remember when neil nielsen something that was
so funny and then i feel like
i can never tell the story right
yeah he knows about getting on the
balcony story wasn't it was windy and
scary and i went back in after
sixty seconds
that was when we were on tour
of course and talking about how nice
our balconies were the interface on your
balconies
oh no i don't know did you
what he's like yeah yeah but it
was windy it's scary i think he
just said yeah and then we had
to ask him how it was really
scary and i came back in and
just
um so yes go go on lorne
you don't want to see that and
why is no no here's what i'm
pitching what it should be so that
i could want to see it okay
so it's gonna be this images work
yeah it's going to be eliot what's
drew barrymore as character's name dirty dirty
you live next door to each other
they're taller mean again it's halloween
she's calling everyone penis breath
that's our catchphrase she is there she
is a single parent now much like
her mom was your than elliott's got
she's been trying to no one will
like
you know be as good as e
t ever was yeah even in her
text so that's so gross and then
some of the kids go to lucky
to live next door
they'll have no shortage in the home
but she'll never to eat oh like
elliot and his wife and kids live
next door or raymond situ heads and
there is a backyard because that connects
the oh and the kids play at
all hours because there's this sort of
safety net of this connecting backyard how's
it going just like a tunnel or
oh with my cousins so there's a
gate that they've connected they've opened a
a connection of fora gate
ah connection of foreign key
yeah so they agar the kids played
all night okay yeah i know your
billions is one night e t s
baby comes to visit tds baby what
about his baby mama
is it just still alive like it's
like baby yoda but it's e t
yeah he's alive but he's he's not
visiting why did they visit in the
first place remember ah there it was
exploration right yeah knowing the science cramp
or something what if what if one
of the samples hook huh what if
one of the samples that they got
they realize when they're all out in
space back at eighties plant
it is necessary to save eighties baby's
life and they need to come back
to get more of i like that
we need more fertile grass yeah pot
i was just thinking these medicinal marijuana
we need sativa what if it's like
e t body e t and his
child have been separated and e t's
baby like baby t is like trying
to find details about the dad where
dad wasn't so he tracks him to
his last known passion earth
and he teed never took off eighty
just wanted to go staley it was
like goodbye you'll always be my birthday
just like went into a cave drinking
hero nine guy i can be your
little money she's pieces all the dooley
knew him for a week talk about
clingy well if you stay and you
know he probably would've affected how elliott
act to the rest of his life
with all of his behaviors
no problem what do you mean like
how they were connected by their soul
oh yeah so so if he ever
like you don't got drunk again elliott
would be drunk yeah who got drunk
e t or yeah it was easy
get drunk i haven't seen the movie
in such a long time yeah he's
home alone and he ah kevin and
he gets drunk and needs rhys
aces and you know i like the
part where the fbi agents point their
walkie talkies at the flying yeah i
hated the bike that was my favorite
part i love that
i've made me want to have a
walkie talkie i eat man i love
doggy dogs we were supposed to get
some walkie-talkies the other day yeah and
who lie first you were supposed to
be in on this but you ended
up not going so we all ah
we're going to magic mountain to see
the christmas lights display i will say
it really worked out that i ended
up miss
thing the ticket sales because i wouldn't
have been able to go really why
because you guys had a show and
it was the timing of you when
you guys actually left at seven one
now also it sucked yeah i was
wondering i was wondering if it sucks
you know because i mean it was
something to do oh i love it
was something to do and it was
fun to go through it's fun to
see you all as kind of a
group but i wouldn't have gone mad
if
i was there but i was curious
yeah i was thinking about it this
morning of like yeah as bad as
it was i will probably reminisce about
it and have fondness for it i'm
so glad we did it but moneywise
yeah it's a ripple oh it's totally
is it really seemed like a save
our park give us yuna absolute likes
to give us sixty dollars a piece
for nothing they they did a lot
little bit less than an average neighborhood
yes like naturally that's known for having
a lot of like watching a great
christmas light fight sting i'm like why
couldn't magic mountain have done that that's
how but they obviously didn't have the
budget for it but um in any
case what were we talking about why
were we saying vt yeah no yeah
and oh boy
oh we were supposed to talk on
the walkie talkies yeah yeah we were
like john first was like we should
get walkie talkies and ah be able
to communicate with each other when we're
all driving because we're all in separate
cars but what about like i'm in
group face-time cool op so get ahead
of it
she's the queen of this so the
cool up was like hey we should
go walkie talkies i said that was
john's idea he already texted so i
bet he's going to do it and
then janey talks about getting walkie talkie
talking about git and get now is
there an app that does talkie none
of us did anything and we were
there so then we face timed we
group face time sorry to skip to
the
end of the story as well as
great as that jon started it and
then did not have his image on
there so it's just a big square
with his initial it's just jay jones
tensing up most of the spring most
of the screen
oh isn't his face yes here i
am j h eugene janey machine that's
from brazil his christmas card is funny
oh i guess i didn't get one
i guess i'd share with you there
yeah oh no it was why would
i get i thought it was just
cute but they put they put the
adults ages as well as the mile
day i tell you there's a video
this is our friend paul john he
put up a video of his daughter
singing tonight you belong to me from
the jerk which is so cute she's
singing for like two minutes every part
of it she's pretending to play a
little guitar and going in by the
line of the silvery moon goes like
segways and doesn't medley with that and
was like yeah it was really funny
to me was then she
takes the guitar and she puts it
in the psalms of a of a
toy yeah like you play this yeah
and it's like what have you saw
that in a concert like here
just me i'll tell you billy joe
today the green day concert got someone
on stage who and taught him how
to play one of the songs is
fucking great
what if i go to a concert
i don't want to see anybody like
me up there yeah i came to
see gave me a fish there's one
video that i recently watched that was
really good it was michael boo blay
having he was doing concert and then
this woman like screams out that it's
her son's birthday oh aaron he's a
singer and he brings
up on stage and plans legitimately good
plant well i don't care for what
the plan was at the plant from
little shop vallejo was over anyways he
was he's got a great voice of
just a mean green mother from outer
space i'm birth i was a part
of this um live reading of that
really has
and some of the michael zoe stories
that story you just told us that's
when we were listening to it
just now i was reading ah know
of little shop yeah who are you
others
i think i was this was like
a couple of years ago i can't
remember but like david arquette was in
it and like no i don't remember
dancing yeah it was a disaster oh
so that's why no i didn't sing
so maybe you weren't odd nobody no
one knowing saying no one saying did
you read the lyrics i honestly can't
yeah well it was a disaster because
the it was um as big of
a disasters when audrey two eighth years
it was just this this this little
performance i was supposed to happen and
it was um everything went wrong that
could go wrong and the electricity one
hour before serving yeah it was truly
a mess
electricity when hour refer it started and
then we had like wait and it
was this why hesitate to throw it
under the bus but it was at
a um puppet theatre in la oh
wow those many puppet theaters in l
a couldn't figure out exactly which one
was chief and so then some puppetry
was happening kind of but the weird
lighting was right yeah
electricity was ah and then we started
we eventually started within like the music
was messed up because of the electricity
problem so it was like a sort
of everyone pulling themselves up by their
bootstraps like make this happen but like
i just yeah it was just not
i was ending it was so long
like sometimes why are we doing this
this i was in a show like
that where they served the were you
in this in the the day the
clown cried santa monica where they served
the seasons assist to pat yes yay
about this yeah we talked about it
but yeah those it's such a such
a sinking feeling in your stomach and
like everything is going wrong on stage
never felt never felt it but just
from what people described to me yeah
usually you're just ah so unaware of
how much you owe
says i would ever imagine feeling not
doing well on stage
i had a friend of mine once
ah who was on a standup but
who was who would you characters and
stuff like that and mr bean ah
yes if i was mr bean who
did characters
these characters would not shut up
characters that were very adroit and they
talked a lot this is like teller
can talk on stage so when you
meet him yeah because yeah chota character
so i can still be dela de
chatty i wanted to see penn and
teller vegas in vegas like a few
years ago and teller whoever who talks
up
man sure like he lost his voice
he was
oh no it was crazy show must
go on though honestly it was wild
okay what we're using so my friend
said i was telling some story about
bombing doing a standup set and my
friend said i've never bombed i don't
know what that slides same also just
it isn't st and then i have
this person on a
a variety show that i was doing
at largo years ago and she did
a character and she fucking bomb when
did you say hey there's a forever
everything never brought it up never ever
mentioned it wow but in my mind
i was like that's what it feels
like maybe she's done that before and
she just ah she's generalized that's balmy
yeah maybe she's like i mean i've
been in front of stupid odd
audiences you don't get what's good but
i've never bombed
wow speaking of bombs you're gonna fart
i like ah oh why nothing hey
it's crazy when bombs go off are
you serious yeah or do you have
a bombing raid drop if no
you don't have a big bombshell your
bike don't have a big bombshell i'm
sorry i i have nothing are we
done
shutting down say we've we've officially ran
out of stuff to say i'm sorry
i want to do a segway thought
something would come up with bobby real
just had what i would consider a
string of a bunch of new stories
and then you killed it
ah you segue to nothing sorry but
i thought it would be there and
just kind of handed did you did
you think you were gonna come up
with something you thought someone else would
fill the void well i thought you
guys would interrupt me like you normally
do and i wouldn't have to say
anything no but i just want to
feel that we only read lauren oh
right yes someone according to one of
our
fans so it's like it's very kind
but very inaccurate because i definitely interrupt
everyone i've done it every five seconds
of this podcast um wait lauren did
you finish what did you want to
see happen with h e okay so
what happens if it was next door
to each other share back yes so
each he comes to earth because he's
tried the baby t and it's really
the q bt bt and mit baby
t he's really cute and wearing a
bitchy a small hoodie has aw didn't
living colour ever do a parody and
just call it bt
call y o e t their parody
v e t s e t and
he's like talks about homies and he
talks about whom
is that the title
he talks about only he's talks
i never even wonder what the title
t i be when i share the
title i think yeah that was a
moment
what
so i never think about what was
on the podcast what the title of
the episode will be oh yeah i'd
ever read about it either it's all
i think about for somewhere just always
trying to say something catching i'm afraid
i'm going to for some reason i
feel like i was making a newspaper
when i was ten when eleven i
go you absolutely did that i have
this image
in my mind of cutting out the
weird flooding out cutting out the the
ad for e t out of the
paper and putting it in my own
papers study as that's a fucking bad
newspaper you made and you're losing money
they're not paying you well now that
everyone's like pivoting to video we would
ah i would
david video of iti you posted this
week that you've posted that you've done
forty episodes of your podcast with janey
yes isn't that shock it's why you'll
you start like a week into the
hell you're early in the pandemic user
that's a good question that i don't
readily have the answer to but if
you guys talk i can look it
up
now talking talking that's crazy
when i saw that i thought you
probably never thought i would go on
that long and for sure yeah that's
almost a year at what are you
guys gonna do for your ah cove
adversity
like coffee into a cup
while my peace deal flipped up
show my he's gonna pee in a
cup like office too
my mouth really well and whatever happens
happens march nineteenth
is your first episode oh i was
like nine days and i feel like
oh i think i think i started
the sixteenth so you did it you
started what ah according ah
march sixteen yeah oh okay okay so
you started it right away right away
oh forty weeks already week and that's
as of this recording forty we're gonna
keep doing grunts when people hear this
it'll be forty forty odd foot of
grunts i'm sorry my friend actually just
had a baby and i think that
means she was pregnancy from day one
one of the pandemic wow so they
fucked immediately they're like getting to your
baby or like we're bored yeah like
who's there to do little new food
oh no
theses people i have friends that i
i've never discussed like having kids with
like we you when you my guys
with wanting your friends yeah oh but
we never talked about it
i've never heard them express like they
want to have children and then they
just had a baby oh it was
such a surprise to me yeah we
live like a topic that we've never
discussed maybe they knew they were pregnant
they're a little bit a little bit
younger than like but like so you're
doing contemporary oh if it's never come
up with a proper
really aren't into the numbers i never
thought it up as she was pregnant
no because they live on the they
live those coast and so i didn't
i had no idea this was happening
oh man it was just like hey
i just want to let you know
tv and st pictures and it was
wow so precious but it was such
a surprise that as a surprise when
you didn't know the person was even
pregnant yeah i have a friend
send who had
he and his girlfriend um were chilling
one night like sex no they weren't
netflix involved they were just hanging around
hanging out this is back in the
nineties oh so that yeah they were
literally just chilling yeah um and going
i wish someone would invent netflix um
all we have are these videotapes um
and then she's like oh my
stomach hurts and they go they go
to the hospital and she has a
baby neither of them knew oh i'm
sorry i was thinking about that the
other day and how because there's a
whole show i didn't know i was
pregnant right you'd have to be so
out of touch i think if your
body into you have no i don't
i
oh just denial about what was happening
maybe i'll just finger bargaining name acceptance
to depression to get through the point
where you remember giving birth i could
imagine remember i mean i know people
who didn't know for like the first
few months but to get to the
point where you were in labor and
you had no idea i'm like well
fur
first of all what the fuck because
you were like they started talking about
it like my friend was like well
we both gained weight we you suddenly
your period stopped her name i don't
know i don't claim to know everything
about the the female body but you
do miss multiple periods right yeah yeah
and you'd probably if that
it happened to me i'd go to
the doctor i'd be like oh i
haven't got my period for eight months
it's a little who knows i mean
no ne usually don't after the first
right you're like oh i'm late was
there a lot of people who don't
go to the doctor when they think
something's wrong because they don't want bad
news you know yeah so true but
that's a baby i know but like
maybe may
maybe they thought it would be bad
news you know like maybe she thought
like oh had a tumor or something
yeah or so who knows but any
case i turned into a wonderful situation
for them both and that kid is
twenty that kid is probably yes probably
malia obama holy shit well no it
wasn't that was it yeah kids probably
probably twenty at this point yeah it's
also just a sign of like how
once your body protects you like if
a person could just go like oh
and then they're just doing whatever for
the whole time and it's like yeah
turn out okay like joint roller yeah
i mean bree knows yeah holding your
belly sheree roller coaster lister yeah deli
meat
i know well that's the thing you
think like how are any of us
here because during the caveman times how
did any of the babies survive but
yeah it just really hate to think
about caveman fucking ah i love it
come on now do you ever see
clan of the cave bear isn't it
gross thing about a cave woman doing
this or something like that and then
the women have to bend over and
i was just talking about clan of
the cave bear are you talking about
is that well it's so we're all
happy that a movie my first girlfriend
in high school she loaned me that
book and told me how i told
the story this is what i liked
they have home cans she she said
this i would like to be treated
this book is very special and important
to me it's beautiful i've never cr
tried reading a book before and so
i started reading these from the bible
i cried on a board mu boy
no job we all got a bag
of joe arguably the most interesting book
probably it's the one with a plot
other than the revelations which is the
fall guy
she made it out like this it's
like side neck important book i say
yeah i just set her up to
it
i just was on um dan klein
and robert pad nix had pad pad
next podcast excuse me aware they read
the bible in roberts podcast robert pad
robert pattinson isn't robert manic climb i
don't know i don't know he's like
a tv writer okay they have a
podcast or they just read the book
bible from start to finish and i
just i was on an episode how
many verses did you have to cover
to i think they call them chapters
o two yeah that's what the bible
i'll tell him i'll tell you it's
really important chapters and verses yeah sure
um but then they apologize because my
section was like really boring yeah i
mean there's whole just parts of it
that
or just boring yeah it's like fucking
the silmarillion edit so marillion how are
you say so this this woman said
this book was really special young ladies
said this book is really special so
i'm reading this book like it's an
important book and then i finally was
like a torture and then i finally
realised oh this is just a garbage
book and i
breeze through the rest of it ah
but then i'd act like yes this
was beautiful was it like a book
report where you had to mention the
parts yes really quizzed me yeah because
old yeller
the army man that was from a
different show laura and that you were
a part of but it's it kinda
sounds like um you're on your phone
i'm listening
just shut up it actually sounds like
what you said was like old yeller
is actually the farmhands name like frankenstein's
actually ah actually old dealers named after
the forehand
they love the farmhand so much they
said let's name the dog after i
always forget that that's a book i've
never read the book and i've never
seen the movie i don't want anything
to do with that movie and the
whole point of it is just that
the dog dies what is the story
of illegal yeah isn't it like marley
and me were like it's all about
the love of a boy and a
dog and then the the ce
sad ending is that marley get shot
i don't know i read some more
of a sounder man myself wow for
that's what i read classic yes did
lassie make everyone think that your dog
should have special powers to like zastava
i mean yeah there are dogs who
bark a lot when i say there's
nothing like my dog has some special
powers mostly being an idiot but i
feel like there's some pretty federal there's
like a sense of she knows what's
going on you know yeah i just
would hate it if like like you
politically in the world like she like
she's protective of course i think if
i'm sad she's like aware right i
would just hate if there
i was a fire in my dog
didn't alert me like what i blamed
the dog like why aren't you more
like these hero dogs that don't allow
dogs sleep in your bed no no
we put them in the crate although
now they like to sleep in the
crate together which is very cute that's
very that makes it better yeah like
i think for warmth purposes but also
molly just like to hell together freezing
well to be honest up there at
night coal cost money
unless santa gives a d keep it
cold
i like to keep it cold because
ah ah yeah i sleep better we
have an issue with our house where
the bedroom gets the most heat in
the house why is that do you
think i don't know yeah having the
sexes
yeah we it comes from us
we we got club got me a
heavy blanket that has holes in it
that makes you feel like you like
it yeah away a weighted blanket but
it's for cooling purposes it's knit so
there's holes so you can just put
a sheet over it and feel like
you're like on vacation
but i feel like michael weighted blanket
and he really likes it but it's
not like that it's like a it's
solid but i sort of think that
might be the one for cooling though
has the the holes in it yeah
well here's the thing is that if
if janey wakes up before me janie
wakes up before xion to turn the
heat up because she's oh yeah hi
nicola it's colder yeah yeah and then
if ah
it's it's i i feel before i
wake up so that when i wake
up i'm groggy yeah like it really
affects me it's wild that i wake
up and then it's just in this
horrible situation like you've been in suspended
animation in alien or something that's exactly
right it's not cool that's exactly right
i'm like gul gul i'm always
surprised when you say you sleep in
i didn't use to i used to
wait for her all the time it
feels like you would be o rise
and shine i used to be a
using now reference no rules kylie kylie
minogue kylie jenner oh she she there's
this video where she was covered all
the
hailes she walks into her baby's room
in shiga she has rise and shine
the senshi things is like really weird
then ever made fun of her and
then she copyrighted rise and shine these
people hey is that why she's a
billionaire this is not a helicopter by
the way this is a plane it's
a plane not we don't know it's
on for planes please
sorry sorry
but so you now sleep late now
actually played yeah of change pandemic oh
really yeah so it's not it was
not even before the pandemic you were
doing no before the pandemic i would
always get up before she did always
always always and now i just well
i'm also staying up later yeah wow
on
on your phone on the computer oh
it's going i play my video oh
that's right yeah that's right well i
wondered that they just had to refund
everyone oh my god cyberpunk twenty two
biot what do you mean no i
didn't i wish i had because i
wanted to play the fucked up version
why did they have to reef because
he was so mad or so there
were so many glitches also for some
reason
and there's you can customize your characters
penis i saw that on dana's instant
like yeah smaller ones got an account
deletion you should care if you wish
great you can go either way it
was shocking to see it i was
like damn alright why is it necessary
yeah way dana like you know dana
whitlow didn't know
i'm always surprised by who knows dana
so i find oh dana and we
are instagram hell ah i mean a
twin dog i was searching for a
gift for my coworker recently and i
was saying to cool up i have
no idea ah what together and and
collapse it oh i'll ask dana and
like they are great friends on
and i had no idea oh and
dean is also really good at um
yeah gif yeah stuff like yeah yeah
we have to take a break good-bye
oh okay
and we're back and ah just thinking
of being back
oh and have anything what about backs
and generalize i had something i was
like oh my god saying i was
gonna say which is that yeah i
just feel like the pandemic has taken
away any positive fucking habit i ever
had like like you're thinking i was
saying like working out being outside a
lot like
um is it about working out that
the pandemic has made scientifically go to
class and now and it's really necessary
for me to like go to a
place and be around people who are
doing it so i'm like yeah motivated
and i just want people can take
pictures of your feet i gotta i
gotta show up barefoot but i feel
like i really liked using the machines
like you know it's just i don't
have any of this stuff and then
that went away i feel like my
phone addiction is skyrocketed yeah my name
is mark by the way i got
you know those alerts every week where
they tell you how much screentime my
guy to shut off ah i got
one the other day that i didn't
think was possible it said
this week you were on your phone
for an average of twenty three hours
a day why i was like why
did you never sleep
that doesn't seem possible sleep scrolling but
the average maybe there was like one
day you know maybe like i don't
one day you were on it for
sixty two hours but then maybe i
thought maybe my computer and phone sync'd
up and now they're saying well you
were on your computer and your flight
so we know that i mean yeah
it's like when i'm not on my
phone i'm on the computer i'm watch
in tv and i if i'm watching
tv i'm on my phone like it's
just there yeah it all goes together
yeah yeah and it's impossible well but
when i get those alerts i honestly
i have said fuck you to them
fuck you fuck they offended me before
the pandemic era and now you i
just let myself do whatever i want
during this time but i yeah but
it's
in my brain i used to read
a lot more yeah i'm sort of
looking at the new year as a
reset for sure yeah it's a good
idea that maybe it'll just it'll just
just a feeling of starting a new
calendar year it is a little i've
always said like january two is national
get shit done day because you get
so many emails of people going like
hey what if we did you know
because it's like everyone's putting everything off
until after the new yeah um but
yeah i think so i mean you
want to put everything off so like
february yeah that since i was doing
really good working out for five days
a week
starting in january during the pandemic all
the way up to my surge and
then i was on my back for
a month and then ever since then
i've been like it's just so hard
when you take that much time off
to get back mentally you know yes
it is so i think but the
good news is is once you do
it the first day you then are
back mentally as long as
you follow it up like yeah the
next day or whatever so and then
you're just like in it again so
yeah there's hope for us all everyone
out there listening yeah yeah same can't
wait to like be able to do
everything like i know for me was
i went to the gym this gym
very close to my house and then
in the absence of that i for
a while i was doing walks around
the neighborhood
yeah i did try was war and
then it was just like i got
tired of seeing yeah i got the
same shit and wearing and wearing the
mask yeah yeah i was doing like
power walks and that was my workout
with like weights in my hands yeah
but like it really alone i really
did i was and i was like
i don't care how dumb i love
yeah just doing something that's a ten
editor
and i then i just was like
this isn't even enough like this doesn't
emphasize we're not seeing anyone for another
three months like let's all work out
starting january because come march or april
whenever we all get the vaccine we
can see each other again we're gonna
be fucking ripped a lot of people
seem to be getting it now i'm
not a lot but i'd feel
like i'm getting the vaccine i know
i read hearing of my sister is
like okay so there's everyone has somebody
but she's a nurse now and they're
all health workers but i'm saying like
well that's the one but i feel
like i know but it feels like
it's happening quickly like right oh my
friend's mom is a doctor she got
it on my friend's wife is a
hospice care work but i say i
went to
the doctor yesterday and and i was
already for this because there's no information
about when any of the regular people
get it like no one's ever said
there's just vague things of leica down
the road so i was all set
to say like all right so when
are we getting this vaccine and he
he cut me off at the knees
even before then saying like ah yeah
this looks good this looks good and
obvious
only you know you're not getting the
vaccine and for a long time so
i was just like fuck a long
time yeah i'm thinking summer do you
say i heard doctor strange got it
yeah is that crazy he wouldn't give
it to wong but he's a medical
doctor that's true and doctor druid doctor
druid
been doing dr drippy and doctor druid
and his doctor druid he was one
of the avengers as well he but
his name was druid even though his
he wore like a cloak and had
all the druid a cute romani yet
yeah his last name happened to be
druid just like doctor strange's last name
is strange true and he's a weird
guy he was
really i mean he wasn't that weird
until he had his accident how funny
is that dr doom's name is victor
von doom but yolo was even worse
was when when they did the reboot
in the ultimate universe they tried to
fix it and called him doctor victor
van dam which is even worse because
john ca
da da so my damn lauren you
have nothing to say about these comic
kara talking about i don't i think
it has to marvel have you ever
read a comic book yeah which one
i've read some graphic novels i wouldn't
say she had a pristine copy of
action comics number
sorry just one of the guys i
left the carver said
by the way are our friend alan
yang was on yeah i saw oh
yeah and that was the question and
i and he was like only eighty
percent sure and i wrote to him
saying obviously i was one hundred percent
sure mike was in a movie about
that comic book that never got released
really really what day it was called
action number one and it was
about these guys like stealing this comic
and oh it just didn't nicolas cage
habit for yeah nick nicholas cage was
part of the part of it he
wasn't in the mood he wasn't in
the movie but they were going to
try to rip yourself yeah there's trying
to come in like hey get out
of here hey b hey hey queen
bee yeah it's gonna be lying i'm
not lying
um
but anyway so i asked me again
if i was lying when i said
i wasn't are you lying yes no
okay um but anyway yeah i read
some comics but i've read some you
know what was fun i might have
mentioned this before but i took my
nephew to a conflict store when he
was visiting la and we we he
randomly picked out a comic book that
was written by scott
oh wow i think you told me
that yeah that was like couple years
ago oh yeah and i said hey
if you want i could give him
a signed copy and you said yeah
i don't think you'd be into that
yes he was like four or five
right right i didn't know when you
said your nephew thought was like yeah
well he didn't understand that anything was
happening yeah that's cool way to come
but now you might want it
that was the spiderman deadpool was out
with yes because it had a picture
of both of them and they're cool
yeah yeah hey deadpool he's very reverend
he's a little too reverend for me
i my issue was essentially him renouncing
his ways and go into church
atoning for his sins that's what i
like to hear yes i told you
about my mom when she saw the
movie flight what's flight like denzel washington
lee worries haha like i'm drunk right
now and he's an alcoholic and but
a great pilot a great plane pilot
and yet he like saves everyone on
board
in a crazy fuckin yeah but they
find out he was drunk during it
and so he goes to trial and
all this and not let him off
the hook for that one and the
very the very ah ah and he
just keeps on backsliding and when he
supposed to go to court they lock
him in a room without any alcohol
and he figures out how to get
into the adjoining hotel room
room and there's like a whole refrigerator
full of alcohol and cut to the
next day every bottle he drank every
bottle and he's drunk anyway so get
over the the very end he goes
to prison and he like gets his
shit together and he becomes ah you
know like a a bible minister man
a bible man in prison so i
thought my
giants would like to write i don't
even know here's the thing people should
not be making movies about the past
unless they're true stories because i'm placing
the past because i'm always fooled into
thinking oh this must be a true
story like the queen's gambit okay right
yeah i thought it was a true
story i'm interested same thing with ah
what's that show ah prentice pash woes
of novel process sapphire push push but
what is what is her name in
today's russia precious suppression i will push
myself very well go the whole movie
thinking is a true story because how
can this many bad things happen to
i would make purse i would you
make up so many horrible things happen
to
oh man you find right and you're
like i'm crying during precious because it's
like this poor person that they based
the thing on and then you find
out it's all fake it's like it's
just a writer playing da movie like
i i like i've told this but
i went to see that with my
sister-in-law and we like first we're getting
to know each other and we went
to the precious by ourselves
vhs and that movie was like the
popcorn trick yeah wow that's so sick
because i was gonna say oh the
part with monique like
oh yeah so fucking gross and so
it's a weird movie to like get
to know someone yeah because you're sitting
there watching money maker daughter yeah it's
like a monique and mariah carey movie
think it's gonna be fun
oh my god i never saw it
yeah because people told me about it
he's like want to see that they
wanted tonight so anyway so flights i
i asked my parents i go hey
did you like flight thinking thinking it
would be up their alley and my
mom's like oh that movie was terrible
i'm like why and she goes he
just kept doing all these terrible things
i go but at the end he
like finds god and puts his life
together she goes he couldn't do that
in minute five
yeah
wow wow wow what she wanted to
be a tick tock where
and then holds the ah
it's pretty funny tiktok
but i guess when you watch something
in people are just making bad that
that is one thing about like watching
the flight attendant like just watching someone
make the worst decisions is very frustrating
as a view yes so i can
understand when uncut gems in people are
like definitely made me so anxious i'm
like it's fake it's it's all fake
yeah like
people were like i i was so
anxious watching
i was like like that's what's your
perfect life that this movie made you
anxious and we all know it's adam
sandler like yeah he's right there up
on like i don't know there was
something about everyone saying that like they
couldn't handle it yeah and i was
like what are you talking i watched
it i thought it was yeah it's
intense you know yeah but it's a
movie yeah yeah i mean yeah point
you can look slightly to the left
or the right and see there's a
wall next you just get on your
phone a different person to come down
movie going it's it's got paul and
lord
this way our review so if a
movie makes you happy or sad you
stupid it's face looking at your phone
no happy and sad i'm just like
fall everyone everyone acting like they couldn't
get through onca domes because it was
like swear did you watch it did
you watch it and watch the helm
yeah well there you go you think
that big screen would extreme when you
can't be on my
yeah giants
going through so many trials and tribulations
he's trying to cut off around the
chest to sign oh i just like
that movie a lot i just didn't
i but i didn't i didn't leave
going leave my couch i'd only make
out
i could couldn't you had to walk
it down the whole time here's pandemic
tips anytime you're done watching anything leave
your couch yeah it means you'll feel
like you went somewhere exactly you know
like go whatever whatever you do anything
leave yes any task anytime you leave
your house and anytime you enter a
room say hi i'm back
alright we have to say greg will
be right back
and we're back and where better than
ever and it's time for a three
cheer and that's better than ever um
this was submitted to us by angella
v vac wow angela vivanco i hope
i'm number one i hope live water
live water
the angel of live water angel of
live water a hallmark original
i don't want to be an angel
anymore it's too stressful i'm only gonna
try to live our live water no
angel has ever drink this live water
and become a human being it's like
splash essentially it's like splash essentially um
this is job interview and angela i've
been looking at lauren we both have
sunglasses on
and then i realize she's not looking
at me but her head is angled
to the point where it looks like
she's looking at me so that i
was just staring at her and fucking
weirdo yeah hey i never i never
said otherwise i'm a widower perf yeah
yeah pervy nice double whammy of a
puff i like to look at people
people watch it it's
gross
this is called job interview okay one
player is the boss interviewing the other
two players who are rivals for a
job opening the boss makes up the
job and the qualifications in the interview
e improvise interview ease rather improvise answers
to the questions okay and i don't
know who wins the the lesnar
boss decides to get the job okay
great so you're the boss laura lee
okay and paul and i are the
applicant arrivals yeah so all ah kind
of gets you into my office and
then we'll discuss what the job is
okay here for the job interview i'm
yeah are you yeah guess they must
be doing
is one after the other i hope
they're not doing us at the exact
same time that would be so boring
anyway good luck man could look to
you to yeah yeah cho and bowed
i'm choked ah hey boat come on
and which one both of you so
what at the same time yes so
what's happening with the habit right now
is that i'm going to ing to
be with you because i don't have
much time actually obey a tight schedule
because i have to go so where
are you going and disney business and
that's a bing against you
hey your loss i think yeah but
i wouldn't have to know where you're
going if i get this job you
would not in this instance have no
i'm going because i'm going to work
here right now hey you're the boss
thank you so much i like this
guy was your name again the de
bode
i'm showed did i remember that one
okay i got a couple of questions
to start off and chota for one
two in the same time showed get
another ding showed a month before i
get the job it's not things positing
based um things are negative in my
mind to make any any pro dings
you're getting dongs and they are working
in your favor but
usually i don't tell you about the
dog showed wants dogs good policy oh
yes thank you thank you dong so
showed you're not getting dogs you're gonna
get things because you are fucking annoying
so i'm gonna ask questions yeah look
i don't like to be talked to
like that from a bowl like to
get a paycheck every week yeah dude
i mean i want this job but
you're you're doing a bad job here
well like i mean this issue seems
i haven't even gotten my first question
okay which question is as follows okay
so obviously you both applying to i'm
looking about toe resumes here and you
both apply resume what are you doing
what are you saying it's pronounced resume
a what is why are you the
word that you said resume you are
okay so you're both applying here to
be shit scoopers for my toilet yes
that's correct
i don't like to flesh it out
like shit to be scooped out and
put into a bucket i read that
ad in the paper made perfect sense
to me i then you want the
bucket to be taken and this would
be a different person from you at
hand the bucket to another person who
then take it and put it into
a plant container where one i thought
i was applying for that job you
didn't maybe we you get to hire
both of us did it
about this bus because i would prefer
the latter job the first question is
as follows let's say my poop wasn't
exactly what to expect it would you
hey
it's multiple choice yeah this'll be easy
would you a i guess see on
every multiple teresa would you okay yep
tell your coworker and you you see
talking negatively about my body okay maybe
it's not your body so it comes
out of your body but go be
would you um just
do with it what you're supposed to
or see fill in the blank see
definitely see okay so what's your answer
i'd fill in the blank what do
you mean what do you mean you're
the one who said see fill in
the blank you have to fill in
the oh shit toad
is not going well i don't want
this job i want the other job
okay why do you want the job
so that i love planners i love
being around them i love being outdoors
i love being in nature i love
the smell of poop old what do
you want so bad i want to
fulfill my potential as someone who can
scoop shit out of a toilet okay
charlie why do you say suicide for
a second i'm gonna just ask bow
to question okay sure just right over
here yeah just a bit further how
far how far do you owe out
to the dorm but still look at
us bowed yes sir
ma'am ma'am bowed if you um what
how much you wanna be paid a
eleven ozawa be two dollars now see
fill in the blank
i'd like to see fill in the
blank and i'd like to fill in
the blank with whatever you think is
fair i think two dollars is alright
and then hopefully if you like the
job that i do maybe i can
get a raise because to be fair
i only shit twice a day max
of course
okay you're very normal so and you're
not gonna spend an hour scooping it
it's gonna you're gonna be paid hourly
but it's not gonna be an so
if i don't fill an hour then
i don't get paid the two dollars
exactly i see huh okay do you
still want me over here i don't
want you anywhere you know ma'am
it's showed baby oh okay so apparently
showed went to the vending machine got
all the snacks out how did you
do that i just tipped it over
and shake shake shake shake those snack
a's that's innovative snack a's yeah i
know what i'm doing and i could
do the same with your buckets i
also went past bay
yeah one time in smash the window
with a hammer took all the cakes
out if that's the kind of thing
you think is good you got the
job thank you bow wow whoa she
was looking at me whoa i don't
care who she was looking for sunglasses
i can't even tell my eyes she's
really cool i don't want to show
you my eyes but you wouldn't have
known long to show us alright oh
god
they're like tiny mouths farting mao this
is like one time i saw a
tv show i think it was jenny
jones she had an afternoon talk show
and she had sheila e on the
show and she he was wearing sunglasses
and they were taking questions from the
audience and someone said could you lower
your sunglasses so we could see your
eyes
eyes and she demurred many times and
then the person would not let it
go and so she finally had to
lower her sunglasses in her eyes looked
very baggy entirely oh and i remember
thinking why may they just let yeah
why members to say she obviously wanted
to yeah have the sunlight if somebody
does it for a reason it's like
only ask once
take no for an answer yeah take
the did you want to get out
of here hey wait what's going on
bode you're hired showed bow tie it
you know what i think i started
doing this yeah we think we're gonna
start our own business we're gonna start
our own ah shit supply but yeah
we both shit and we both like
to scoop shit yeah it's like planners
yeah what do we need you for
wow i gave you
the idea you and your weird shits
well you don't even know if they're
weird they do look like eminem's but
that's weird
but that's also a familiar object it's
true true it's like you're shitting out
a chaebol it has never been seen
on a real nut drum
okay we'll stay but we're gonna share
the job okay so that's one dollar
per hour each how will make it
last to an hour though wait what
happens if we don't make it last
for an hour it's five cents you
know that kind of thing flat rate
five seconds
so it's up to a dollar an
hour
ah well how many censor dollar sixty
how many seconds are in a minute
sixty so it's a penny and we
go back one
alright so the end ah wonderful alright
kind of nice guy would you like
to be the butler i'll be the
boss
i'm a little nervous i'm very confident
oh well that's nice i this is
actually my fifteenth interview this week anyway
it's my first ever
hello never had a job oh hello
hello um i ah i'm the person
who's going to be interviewing you both
ah my name is dr weird blessings
to you on this morn
so much the traditional breeding of my
people how did you know i researched
you a bit before i came the
weirdos what's up doctor remember from the
cartoons
okay well um which one of you's
lingua e ca me and which one
of you is barf
who wouldn't it be the other purse
it's not me also barf didn't make
it how many names you have on
there three hundred what's the next name
okay just run down home until i
get to yours or you could tell
me now i'd prefer for you to
tell me i'd actually like to hear
some of them just wanna make sure
i'm on the list i'm just glad
i got i was right there at
the top
well they're done by time are you
really early um oh hell is it
really earlier what time is your appointment
two thirty two thirty that's four hours
away i just wanted to make sure
that it was on time okay to
thirty you must be absolved men yep
oh okay great i'm absolved men absolved
men as
handling wicca when rica at your service
i would here's what i'd like to
do i would love to interview you
both at the same time ah four
hours
okay i can do okay cut to
four hours later well we're back you
guys ready we've stared at each other
this entire four hours i appreciate you
waiting for my appointment time i don't
care i'm gonna get this job you're
late already by the way so you
think that's my style alright well come
on come on back here just to
be fair
when winger was here at his point
true but he didn't want to be
interviewed until four hours after his appointment
so that all you wanted to interview
us both at the same time and
absolve mmo was early hoisted by my
own petard that's right come on back
into doctor weir's office what do you
say it's still you right that's me
all right speaking in the
first person or thirty wide your hawaii
guy deflate oh well it's a long
story but ah i took him to
hawaii with me and to revisit his
hometown yeah just just show him his
mother soil
and common for israel yeah you rub
his face in it literally and unfortunately
the jagged rocks you know yeah those
jagged rocks on the beaches yeah and
killed him they killed him anyway this
isn't my job interview this is your
job can be killed him ah guys
here's the deal i'm interviewing you to
be the ceo of this company did
i get the job yes wow
now interview both of us oh okay
hello likely many times do you think
you could do the job the best
way once and only once well you
know what does that mean exactly well
there's a right way and the best
way to do the job as the
police are here and i think they're
searching for me oh this is awkward
as there this is not really a
job no
i basically i need to do to
take over the company to be the
patsy
because i've been embezzling for the last
forty minutes you probably should not have
told me that part because i'm just
gonna say it was you dazzling for
forty minutes yes i love to turn
it around it was so fun well
look i'm gonna leave because i don't
want to be a part of this
and i didn't get the job and
this is always my time i've lot
outdoors this is a problem i just
don't see how this plays out so
i'm gonna stick around that's the crucial
you just locked the door from the
inside yeah hey matt lauer let us
out of here
hey all right just unlocking bed guys
i miss you already
our real selves are the characters good
luck in jail
hey i don't need luck
scene
oh boy alright paul is a great
game no you're the bad
welcome to the job application as you
both here what do you imitate me
what a weird wave talking that's you
a very old yoshii how old are
you i'm seventy and i don't have
a lot of time to this god
how do you think you're gonna die
are you sick or early years have
a series of ailments that i'll compound
one another
oh i wanted to say that i
should whip a snap but they get
this job for many reasons the hold
on your name's i'm seeing ah trolley
and a bebop he said correct
it's i'm rock steady actually not be
i'm trolley biba oh that's the food
trolley beat out the rock steady bebo
yes we were brother and sister there's
just brothers insisted okay now that this
job is very delicate it's it is
to ah you have
have to once i die you have
to then kill my wife so it
can be a beautiful story where she
died of a broken heart just days
after i die ah how do you
plan on dying well now i plan
on succumbing to my various illnesses all
at this age have you want your
wife to die if i well i
want to make it look like she
died of a broken heart okay but
i do want you to cut her
head off
okay well with what with a butter
knife oh yeah it'll take forever exactly
and always finish with a butter knife
after using a ship or two how
about this i'll let you start with
a butter knife switchover a bread knife
go back to the butter knife could
we kill her and knife on the
neck sounds like it would
hurt because we inject her with something
so she's dead and then enjoy you
start with a butter knife because i
feel like her squirming she's deathly afraid
of needles okay but not better knives
well not not so far
what if i killed you and then
you were just dead well i mean
i'm going today anyways so that's a
waste of time yeah why go to
jail for something that's going to happen
anyway now you can just go to
a funeral your qualifications that was part
of the game what are they have
you killed anyone before i kill
for deer with my arms and i
killed two dogs and flow frogs and
i've killed one woman and i didn't
get killed one hog oh okay good
and the i've killed one
frog
back down to one frog let me
ask you this when you feel dive
yes alright one cat and i've killed
one bat and i killed three rats
let me say you're killing that hat
it looks great i died one matt
and wow
one child keeps going and i'm gonna
ask him i killed have you ever
killed a woman i don't have a
resume quite like that one but i
i think i've probably killed some people
in with like i lived cutting glance
or a sarcastic quip oh hi today
and one train um and i've guide
no i haven't killed anyone per se
but i'd like to i've always wanted
ten die i'd say i can work
with that yeah i'm interested in it
certainly one way to do you are
you and your behavior that you will
be afraid carry out the girls started
it and i've killed i think it's
the starting of it is the part
that never has been able to get
over the hump i think once i
start it's kinda
like well i gotta finish it now
wow wow do i know that you're
actually doing and i've key i could
sign something one or promise you or
okay do i have to give you
a special handshake around let me think
about that handshake and an object i
killed okay with yeah charlie be one
doe
and i've killed probably boot up i'm
gonna stop you there what when you
kill the woman what method did you
use how did it go i used
a butter knife and a bread knife
who wait a minute and it went
good okay i gotta say she killed
her mom by the way if she
oh i forgot your brother's history yeah
she's in
lead so far well but i think
the the the thing that gives me
a slight edge and the yohei and
stammering hey would you make fun of
our president that way which would joseph
r biden joseph robinette biden robin hood
biden joseph robinette biden
joseph robin tag biden
look i yeah she's better at it
than me she tried to kill me
once is that so try me well
but guess what
i escaped is that so rarely bba
it's all true everything he ever utters
he can tell no lies is that
correct and you always lie and i
killed one bud eagle and
oh one vo i'm very high yachting
is wow love it or leave it
writes her and iser am i'm like
you worried whoa let me kill your
wife sir
right i told rapper in a flag
will you bury your seat next to
a solid block of course right on
top oh that's where america deserved to
be less alright i've made my decision
oh boy i can't wait for this
me please stand at attention hut hut
hut
i am ready to make my choice
yes sir q music katya sir hut
you know my years of being alive
i never thought i'd be dead and
not have anything going on afterwards but
now that is the case
charlie bebop
was your name again
rocksteady rocksteady bebop
i've called you both in here because
i've made a decision yes i have
decided
to drink the immortality potion ah forever
oh wow already killed your wife you've
passed my test yes you get the
keys so shall my word that three
like you
why do you have in here oh
tons like places lousy with them
the end yeah we did it we
did that was us wayne and yeah
guys that's gonna do it for this
episode of threesome but um remember you
should listen to other ones i don't
know what are we what are we
supposed to say without an instagram yeah
and an instagram
threesome usa on instagram and later and
if you want to listen to other
episodes and even future ones ah head
over to stitcher premium and you can
hear other episodes yeah yeah but thanks
for listening and listening subscribe until your
friends please do that we'll be back
next week and until then goodbye
lie and only until this
uh